you know when you buy some [ __ ] on like  a designer website and the dude looking  at you is just crazy looking like this  guy is like six seven yeah just  I don't look like that when I put these  on even the guys that I saw when I went  to that Dior thing and I like saw them  in person yeah it was like what do your  parents look like yeah yeah they'll be  pale as hell eye sockets are sunken in  hella deep bright piercing blue eyes  yeah and their hair is naturally  translucent yeah  they have clear hair yeah somehow wow  not bald if clear braids and and even  the way they mix and match it you know  they'll wear some windbreaker material  with dress shoes yeah [ __ ] that should  not go together no shirt yeah yeah and  you put it on your little body and  you're like I think I just saw Mr  tumness walking down the street looking  dude from Narnia just like the small  little man with the hood feet I gotta  get a picture of this guy  oh